now underneath this heading I've asked
you to draw this up basically correct
angle triangle again and um you can
label it accordingly so all we know
about this triangle at the moment is
that it's right-angled and everything
else is kind of up for grabs there are
all pronumerals they could be equal to
anything right now in this triangle if
we say theater is this guy in the corner
like I said it was up here then you can
tell me what sign theater is equal to in
this particular triangle what is it in
this triangle a over C is opposite on
hypotenuse very good likewise you can
tell me cos theta will not be a over C
it'll be BOC and then you finish off
with tan which is opposite on adjacent
okay now in other words and this is
worth arm worth writing down in other
words we think of these trigonometric
objects we think of them as ratios all
right it's this side over that side and
we just compare different ones okay so
that's why this began we're thinking
about trigonometric ratios that's why
every time you need a triangle every
time you need a triangle but when I
started out this topic I said to you
trigonometry is important to us as human
beings because it appears in more than
just right-angled triangles they're kind
of hiding in lots of other places and so
to illustrate that what I want you to do
is underneath this triangle I want you
to draw a nice big Cartesian plane maybe
let's see maybe 10 centimeters high
10 centimeters across ten by ten so draw
me a nice Cartesian plane
[Applause]
now go over the page that's fine yes
can you not see that's um yeah yeah it's
a perfect perfect scale that's exactly
ten centimeters I'm measured out very
carefully on your Cartesian plane I want
you to draw an object that might be a
little bit surprising with its center at
the origin I'd like you to draw me a
circle make it as large as you possibly
can on your Cartesian plane what what
okay now you ten yes all the way across
and I think you'll pay most people's
pages are not big enough to go yeah okay
now I'm gonna ask her something which I
don't I don't usually ask for because I
don't usually like it but in these
circumstances we're gonna need it I'm
gonna ask you for this next party
explanation to be silent not because I
don't want you to speak but because I
want your concentration to be intense
because this is a really hard idea
people all the way up until the end of
year 12 if they don't learn it properly
in you 10 they just never understand it
okay so I know you guys can get it and
that's why I want you to focus really
clearly if what that requires is that
you don't have a pen in your hand and
then don't put a pan you're here but if
you can't draw and listen hard then do
that but don't speak I need your mind
engaged not your mouth this is a circle
it has its center at the origin to make
a circle to define a circle you need to
know where it is and you also need to
know how big it is this is a particular
circle with a radius of one so from the
center to this edge would be one up to
the top would be one if I continue that
you can see over to the left hand side
this is going to be negative one and the
same down here this object is really
important when it's Center is at the
origin and it's radius is one we call it
and you should label it as such we call
it the unit circle unit as in one you
know like a unicycle has one wheel so
this is the unit circle now sine cos and
tan we've been very used to we've only
ever defined them and thought of them in
terms of right angled triangles but in
fact they are hiding inside the unit
circle if we know how to see it now if
you can grab another color and to help
us see
where sine cos and tan are hidden inside
here I want us to start by imposing a
right angle triangle inside we're going
to get rid of it eventually but I want
to find it in there first so draw a
little triangle like this but watch how
I do it I'm gonna start from the origin
I'm gonna go to some spot on the
circumference like so and that's going
to be the hypotenuse of my right angled
triangle then you can draw a leg down
and a length across there's my right
angle triangle just like in this one I'm
gonna put theta here in the corner and
now I'm going to think about how to find
the trigonometric ratios tucked inside
there okay this right angle triangle
starts at the origin it's a hypotenuse
starts at the origin and goes through
the circumference so therefore without
any calculation because you know what
kind of circle this is you can tell me
what the length of the hypotenuse is
what is it it's just one because it's
the radius right does that make sense
this is in the unit circle so from the
origin to anywhere on the circle you
have a distance of one but that means I
can find out these lengths just like you
found them out in the review questions
right because if you think about this
right if these coordinates here are x
and y right the coordinates of this
point on the circumference then that
means x and y are lengths on this
triangle right where is X if X would say
something like half right then it would
mean from the middle here you go one
half of a unit across and that's your x
coordinate right so therefore this is
going to be X that's what the x
coordinate means start from zero and go
to the right that many units okay where
would Y be it's that vertical length
isn't it right inside that right angled
triangle it's the height here okay now
just like you did this triangle you can
stay sine and cos and tear
in terms of these legs here right in
terms of the ratios that you know so in
this triangle let's start with sign what
is sine theta in this particular
triangle
well it's opposite on hypotenuse do you
agree which is just Y over one so the
other one doesn't change anything we
divide by one the number is the same so
therefore Y is sine theta that's a bit
weird
we've been attaching sine and cos and
tan to angles but this tells us you can
actually use them to also describe
lengths I can use exactly the same logic
to think about cause cars is going to be
adjacent hypotenuse in this triangle
what is a JSON or hypotenuse it's x over
one which just like before the over one
doesn't change anything
so therefore this X is simply equal to
cos theta okay now what that means is
you see how I said oh the coordinates
are x and y well now I know what x and y
are I don't have to call them I don't
have to have new pronumerals I can use
the pro noodles I've already got I can
call them the x coordinate is cos theta
cos theta and I can call the y
coordinate sine theta okay now that's
weird
I'm not used to thinking of I'm
trigonometry in the context of
coordinates let alone circles but this
is true the trigonometric ratios told
you they were the case okay now what's
beautiful about this is therefore and
don't don't destroy this on your diagram
I'm just going to do it on this one
we put this triangle unit here to help
us understand things but if I got rid of
the triangle everything we said about
all of these lengths and the right angle
triangle that we imagined all of these
things are still true they're no less
true than they were before
it's just that how we got them is now
from view okay so therefore here are the
trigonometric functions they're not
ratios anymore they're not ratios or we
don't have to think of them because what
are they the ratios of there's no
triangle in here right I'm just thinking
of it in terms of this circle okay so
the heading that I asked you to leave
space for is no longer trigonometric
ratios we now call these guys even
though they're made of the same DNA we
call them the trigonometric functions
that's a really good question and I'll
come to it after we land what's going on
now before we before we answer that
question we've got cos and sine but I
promised that we would also define tan
right will also define tan now if you
think back you because you guys still
have that triangle in front of you right
tan is going to be opposite on adjacent
right opposite on adjacent so that's
going to be Y over X do you agree y over
X but hold on a second we know what Y
and X are we know what they're equal to
there's sine theta and cos theta so I
don't need to think of tan as opposite
or adjacent I can think of it just in
terms of sine and cos and the angle
wherever you happen to be